that's not gold paint on the bridge
behind me those are tens of thousands of
padlocks put there by couples wanting to
symbolize their everlasting bond a bond
that will no doubt hold them together
into eternity as they steadily grow
apart and more resentful of the other
eventually spiraling down into death
always wondering what would have
happened if they made different choices
along the way my issues aside it's also
a pretty good example of the difference
between fantasy and reality because
those locks will not stay there for
eternity they will eventually rust and
fall off or the council will come along
and take them off with bolt cutters as
happens fairly often and that difference
between fantasy and reality is the basis
of something called Paris syndrome and
what it is is a syndrome that affected
mainly Japanese tourists to the tune of
about 20 a year who would be so
overwhelmed by the difference between
their expectations of Paris as this City
of Light and romance and wonderful
architecture and art and food and
everything and the reality which is a
fairly dirty and polluted European City
the same as London or Berlin or any
other like it the symptoms well they
could be anything from delusions or
hallucinations all the way to
tachycardia which is irregular heartbeat
another psychosomatic symptoms is it a
real thing well it's difficult to tell
because it does have journal articles
about and it does have scholarly
references and news articles but I
suspect if you looked at most cities
with a big tourist industry you have a
good number of people sent home just
overwhelmed with jet lag and
homesickness every year the fact that
it's Paris and it has this reputation
well perhaps people are drawing a little
too much signal from the noise of people
just not able to cope with being away
from home either way it's Paris syndrome
it's something you might not have known
I think I found the Evian bottling plant